aber nette jetzt doch endlich event
können in elster park endlich enthüllen
da auch ich komme ja schon
[Applaus]
geht heutzutage
nicht mehr zu stellen hallo leute
hier ist wieder eure mal wandert und
willkommen zu einem neuen
adventskalender video
heute packen wir den rentner
adventskalenders sind ein paar jahre
vergangen wir haben das jahr
2070 und ich hoffe und stets ein gut
aber mein dekolleté habe ich gut
eingecremt über die jahre
ich kann das video jetzt nicht also denn
dadurch ziehen also haben heute gehen
sie doch mal willkommen zur neuen
adventskalender auspacken video ihr habt
mich in den kommentaren hundertmal
danach gefragt wann geht es wieder ganz
kalender auspackt videos und links an
genau jetzt jetzt ist der start und wir
fangen wir besser an als mit einem
rentner adventskalender ich bin zwar
keine rentnerin aber
vielleicht kann ich doch die ein oder
andere sache dazu sagen vielleicht fühle
ich jetzt den spirit jetzt muss ich mal
ganz kurz in meiner unterlagen gucken
was die saarländer gekostet hat
[Musik]
hier habe ich die rechnung
der kalender hat
22 eur 95 gekostet das sind fast 50 dem
abpfiff mit
kraft
[Musik]
befreien wir ihnen erst mal von seiner
verpackung
da ich noch nicht in rente bin weiß ich
jetzt natürlich nicht was man im renten
leben so alles braucht ich hoffe aber
dass der rentner adventskalender tolle
sachen beinhaltet die meinem
rentnerdasein freude bringen also wir
beginnen leute geht wieder los leute es
geht wieder los wir packen jetzt hier
aus und fängt an mit tüchern nummer eins
was erwartet uns natürlich nummer eins
mit wird mein rentnerdasein schöner
gemacht
hammer
genau das brauche ich auch nicht ganz
fantastisch ich würde sagen eine orange
eine reine bienen honig wachs kerze das
sehr gut bei manche wachskerzen sind
giftig
das mit dem gedächtnis wird im alter
wirklich nicht besser
schön so leitet man natürlich auch gut
die adventszeit ein wir müssen nicht das
türchen nummer
zwei
doch da werden wir verwöhnen
himbeermarmelade
ohne kerne natürlich schönsten
guttenberger milliarde zeit und york
steht doch braucht zeit für ein
gemütliches frühstück klar und für ein
gemütliches frühstück brauchen eine
kerze und händler marmelade natürlich
ich habe ein bisschen das gefühl dass
jetzt hier wirklich auch nur aufstriche
drin sein werden wir finden es heraus
türchen nummer drei klar grüner café ok
davon habe ich noch nie gehört
mein enkel hat mir gezeigt wie ich das
hier benutze der grüne kassel wird aus
grünen und umgerüsteten boden
hergestellt genießen sie den
einzigartigen geschmack des grünen
kaffees pur nach dem sport klar oder
nach jeder mahlzeit
um diese uhrzeit jetzt kann ich keinen
kaffee mehr drin aber zu frühstück auch
mal was neues entdecken
na klar ich wollte schon immer ein
haufen hotel artikel in meiner wohnung
haben nuss nougat creme von nudossi sagt
es nicht meine man aber ich probiere es
mal ganz kurz
eine gute nuss-nougat-creme also da kann
ich nicht jeden morgen auf das stück
freuen
honig hammer also ich muss sagen bis
jetzt gefällt er mir sehr gut weil wenn
ich mir zum beispiel vorstellen
ich schenke den meiner oma die in polen
lebt und ich nie sehe das ist doch nett
bis doch nicht da sagt man sich um eine
holde und honig brötchen oder macht das
immer ein zäher ein türchen nummer sechs
wir sind jetzt beim nikolaus nikolaus
[Applaus]
ja es sind bauernfrühstück produkte aber
ich finde das ganz nicht
ich werde ein instant salbei und honig
portion für eine tasse mit vitamin c
wichtig wichtig nach belieben mit honig
nach süßen
netz man muss es auch sagen ist es ein
nikolaus türchen gewesen
weil sie nicht ich mich noch mal wieder
teurer ist das denn obstwiese apfelkraut
ich bin überrascht ich kenne die hälfte
der sachen mich also apfelkraut
er schmeckt wie apfel karamell bis in
essig michael sauer wegen apfelwein
konnte ich freu mich darauf dass morgen
auf meinen pro zu schmieren vom
verschafft da das ist die das sind die
die auch diesen zuckerrübensirup haben
okay leute ich habe das gefühl nicht
auch hier ins rentnerparadies ein
wahrscheinlich kennt ihr alle produkte
und ich bin nur hinterm mond
aufgewachsen aber ist
die nummer
café
afrika-cup damit ich will fährt zusammen
gearbeitet wo ich auf siegel und sowas
hingewiesen habe und das fällt mir
gleich alles aufgeben das fairtrade
siegel das eu bio siegel
instantkaffee
austrainiert lieblingszahl türchen
nummer 9 hier haben wir getreidekaffee
instant getreidekaffee
der kaffee lastig das ist alles für
meinen mann nein
hahaha das ist koffeinfrei
getreidekaffee das wollte ich immer
schon mal ausprobieren es ist aus roggen
sich orient glas die eicheln freien
trinkt zurzeit immer koffein freiwillig
aber erzählt ich vertrag kein kaffee
mehr weil meine angst zustände dadurch
getriggert werden
deswegen bin ich jetzt auch koffeinfreie
umgestiegen und das geht voll klar also
ich habe jetzt auch keine probleme mehr
das ist jetzt schon wochen her das ist
cool mal alternativen noch zu probieren
und hier haben wir den oci gold saft
zuckerrübensirup den kenne ich aber ich
mochte ich nee das ist aus 100%
zuckerrübe aber es könnte sein dass mein
geschmack sich jetzt verändert hat
ich bin älter geworden
ich glaube so weit bin ich noch nicht
dass ich diesen trüben saft mag sagt mir
bitte nicht dass ihr das gerne auf euer
brot speditiven zuckerrübensirup kann
das nicht versteht kann den geschmack
hat wenn es zeit da trinkt dann doch
gerne meinen cacau so macht man sich
noch ein zwei marsch - obendrauf sagt
eigentlich zu meiner beste leute
trainern sie bei euch auch
kindheitserinnerungen bei mir extrem
guten morgen bio kräuter teleskop mich
auf meine fingernägel
blackberry ließ papst robert händel uhr
kommt leider klingt sehr gesund klingt
sehr lecker schmecken da werde ich doch
gerne zum rentner
es geht wieder viel zu schnell ich weiß
ihr wollte ich genau so wie ich drei
stunden weiter marmeladen anschauen
aber es kommen noch ganz viele andere
adventskalender darauf könnt ihr euch
aber gefasst machen die nummer 13
das habe ich nicht erwartet
canela kräuter leber schweinefleisch
bergwasser schweineleber schwarten
sondermüll speisesalz
konservierungsstoffe
nicht weiß kleve
pressetext rose ist aber auch ein mann
sagte mal hier in diesem veganen
produkten sind so viele schnickschnack
sachen drin da ist genauso viel
schnickschnack drin der hätte ich mir
gewünscht dass man den renten gude
vegane leberwurst rheinpark hier sehe
ich kein bio drauf schlüsselnummer 14
heiß war bot jetzt wiederholen sich die
sachen heißer holunder hier ist mit
vitamin c und magnesium
ja jetzt wieder wenn sich die sachen ab
der hälfte gibt aber sehr heidelbeer
marmelade
eigentlich
der kommt aber auch ein bisschen spät
ehrlich gesagt ein guter spritzgebäck
keks mit marmelade in der mitte
natürlich
ich hab nix gesagt mensch wg teller also
das ist glaube ich vom gleichen
hersteller
veganes tomaten basilikum
aufstrich man kann die oma kac nach
mensch lisa ich habe da letztens in
meinem kalender mégane aufstrich
gefunden ganz lecker dann werde ich das
mal öfter kunden 18
das fehlt mir ein bisschen in diesem
adventskalender bratapfel tiefen ein
bisschen festlich weihnachtszeit
genießen
das einfach so brände unkommentierte
zwei spielarten herzen sind ja ich darf
das auch nicht aber ich muss ja
probieren wie die sprache von lindt
den spieß einfach lecker türchen nummer
also ich muss jetzt ehrlich sagen ich
glaube meine oma wusste nichts damit
anzufangen aber ich bin mega geil ich
hoffe dass wir nicht gerade zum
geburtstag geschenkt bekommen diese wie
nennt man das heuchert türmchen da
vertreibt die oma am morgen erstmal
schönen die bösen geister aus der
wohnung sinn macht man sich das nur zu
hause ankommt dann braucht man erstmal
schöne dicke tüte und dann hat man seine
bude aus ist dafür ein duft aber
cool ich finde es mega kult für mich
wäre auch so eine esoterik
adventskalender voll was zu kristallen
drin räucherstäbchen
21 etwa
marmelade in marillen geschmack auch
eine frucht ich sehr seiten es die
nummer 22
wieder honig aber dieser clique es gibt
ja so dicken honig und so flüssigen ich
mag da habe ich den dickflüssigen
irgendwie lieber könnt ihr mal die
kommentare schreiben warum es
dickflüssigen gibt also warum ist der
dick für das hier in der andere nicht
ist da also gibt's welcher und wo ist
der unterschied so ich brauche ich hier
gerade meine bude so weg da frage ich
mich wirklich kennen sie damit was
anfangen
türchen nummer 23 noch mal kaffee wir
hatten lange keinen kaffee kaffee bio
von schweizer organic instantkaffee bio
löslicher kaffee ja gut und jetzt ist
der tag gekommen
ich bin rentner ich war gerade auf die
knochen tut schon weh aber alles ist
noch gut ich habe ja meine enkel die
sich regelmäßig bei mir melden und meine
kinder und alle lieben milch und dann
sehe ich oh das ist ja heute weihnachten
eigentlich abend 24 und dann macht das
tier und süden ab voller vorfreude und
fände
oma hartmann
[Musik]
kalter hund
mein gott wie kuchen der hund ist nicht
fliegen da sind kekse
eigentlich kennt auch jeder kalter hund
muss ich unbedingt mal selber machen
warum heißt das eigentlich kalter hund
schmeckt ganz okay es sieht ein bisschen
dran also nicht kann sich im sinne von
alt ist sieht halt so ein bisschen froh
ich bin mal geschmolzen wenn die schon
lindland herzen rein gemacht haben warum
haben sie dann nicht so kleine schoko es
gibt doch das ganz kleinen link
weihnachtsmänner er hätte dann bestimmt
reingepasst so aber was halte ich denn
jetzt nun von diesem adventskalender
ich muss sagen ich finde es allerliebst
außer das ding hier also töte euch hier
mir echt alles weg vielleicht sollte man
auch nicht zehn minuten daneben sitzen
ich finde den kalender richtig süß ich
bin echt
22 95 23 euro na gut man kann jetzt
sagen für 43 euro kann ich aber fünf von
diesen packungen holen aber dann hat man
halt nicht diese vielfalt 22 euro dann
sage aber ich finde ihn süß ich finde
also gerade so wenn man daran denkt es
ist so ein frühstücks kalender ist ich
stelle mir das richtig nett vor dass man
so
rentner dann ist diese dinge geschenkt
gekriegt hat und wie man jeden tag unser
bild tun aber vielleicht habe ich auch
rentner falsch im kopf die sind voll
peking und sagen
ich kann es leider nicht beurteilen
ansonsten freue mich auf das nächste
adventskalender video leute und bis
dahin ist eure vitamine trinkt viel
wasser und macht viel sport und lebt das
leben denn morgen könnt ihr schon
aussehen wie ich oder ihr seht schon aus
wie ich dann viele grüße und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten mal wieder bis denn
antenne eure
[Musik]